he's the star tight end for the
Minnesota Vikings he's Kyle Rudolph and
a proud alum of elder high school I did
some research on you Kyle and I have
been there for an elder football game
what did they do they split it like
50/50 do they do that in the crowd with
money you remember that all the splits
apart yeah yeah that's a big deal
especially you got about 12,000 people
in there and I think that's what people
look forward to most not the game but
how am i hard to split the power we'll
get and I remember seeing Kuechly in
high school and I went that guy seems
like he's all over the place there he's
he's pretty good and then he went to
what Boston College I sort of lost track
of him
whereas I remember you were a great
basketball player I remember more of you
for basketball than I do football how
close was it that you were gonna play
basketball in college you know it's
something that I think back to as a 16
year old kid I always tell people you
know it kind of just worked out with
football I don't really ever remember
making a decision or thinking to myself
you know choosing football over
basketball because I love both of them I
had so much fun playing basketball I was
fortunate enough to have scholarship
offers both in football and basketball
but you know it's certainly hard for me
to think back and say oh well what if I
would have picked basketball instead of
football you know having been in
Minnesota for almost ten years and you
know being settled here playing in one
place for this long has been pretty cool
if you didn't go to Notre Dame where
were you going you know I made my
decision early in the recruiting process
but a lot of the other schools that I
liked a lot were in the SEC like
Tennessee Florida LSU my family was
certain and I chose four hours from home
and they were able to come to every home
game and then you know we played about
two or three Big Ten schools every year
as well which was all within three hours
at home I I found out don't you have a
big tattoo of a line on your chest
yes okay but you're in the division with
the Lions I know so my wife would let me
get a panther you know the elder is the
Panthers yeah let me get a panther so
then I had to go back to the drawing
board and do some research and figure
out you know what what's important it's
actually funny so before I wore purple
at Elder I went to an elementary school
called visitation and we were the
visitation Vikings so my life has come
full circle I'm now a Viking and I wear
purple and I still go back to the
Panther thing I you know I don't have to
talk to your wife about that I think I'd
rather you had a panther than a lion
even though you know Kiki might give you
grief though if you go oh you got a
panther on there yeah so to finish the
story you know I did some research and
you know I around the line is a bunch of
flowers and it's the burst flowers of my
daughter's my wife and my mom and the
lion is a protector of okay the herd so
that's why we went with lion you know
kind of the King if you would not
because of the Detroit Lions
he's Kyle Rudolph the Vikings tight in
you got an update on Delvin cooks injury
Oh
Alvin's been battling all year I mean
when you carry the ball as many times as
he has you know you get bumps and
bruises but you know he's a fighter and
you know we've no doubt as good as he
can to be out there he's every week
what do you see different with the
current cousins I think the biggest
thing about Kirk is we're doing things
offensively to put him in in comfortable
situations you know what latias played
out you know we got into situations
where games turn into drop back passing
games drop back there on the ball 38 40
45 times and no matter how good your
offensive line is if your quarterbacks
dropping back to the same spot every
single time the rushers in this league
are just too talented
and this year we've gotten back to
running the football more moving the
pocket making things a little bit more
unpredictable for defenses and
especially for rushers because they
can't just pin their ears back knowing
that the quarterback is going to be at a
spot right behind the center and get
there I know you got some spotty cell
service here so let me get the sponsor
mentioned here American Cancer Society
crucial catch program Kyle's joining us
on behalf of that with the NFL minimum
ten dollar donation fans can win the
experience of a lifetime at the Super
Bowl
including the tickets to the game where
they get to sit with a celebrity get
sideline passes access to parties and
more so fans can donate to win at
crucial catch dot nfl.com and kyle also
the Vikings Walter Payton Man of the
Year nominee for the third straight year
great stuff hope the family has a great
holiday and good luck the rest of the
regular season and in the post season
thanks Dan I appreciate it always a
pleasure being on that's Kyle Rudolph
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]